and if you doubt angela davis because i
generally
doubt the things that communists tell me
though she has been prominent for many
years
take it from biden himself who just
recently quoted
chairman mao one of the most
blood-soaked communist dictators in
history
biden quoted mao he thought he was
quoting quote an old chinese proverb
and and the prophet is this biden said
according to news reports
women hold up half the sky so it's an
old chinese proverb
it's not that old it's a saying of mao
zedong
mao zedong said this because he wanted
to make the argument that women were an
important
labor resource and women needed to leave
the home
and shouldn't be homemakers anymore and
should go out and work in the fields
and work in industry and advance the
cultural leftist revolution so you got
the guy
already now promoting the explicit
sayings
of communist dictators not not a good
position to be in even joe biden who is
probably the most moderate guy left in
his party really is just an empty suit
who licks his finger puts it up in the
air and figures out which way the wind
blows
joe biden now is seating all that ground
to the radical left
and they're going to they're going to
continue to exploit it time
and time again as we get closer to
november
and they'll use that fault line that
power of melanin that weak spot on race
but this is all about a radical ideology
and and when their efforts fail when
they fade away when the race riots ebb
and the people stop caring about the
lockdowns that are going to kill
2 million or 10 million people and the
predictions don't don't come true
they'll find some other crazy way to
distract you so much of this
seems to be about distractions
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary
invoicing software for contractors and
small businesses
spend less time billing and more time
making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description